in the lobby of Ramsey solutions dan and
Mary are with us hey guys how are you
hey how you doing welcome where you guys
from what we're Texas all the way to
Nashville yes sir and I assume you're
here to do a debt-free screen and we are
good deal and how much have you paid off
one hundred nine thousand dollars way to
go how long did that take thirteen
months whoa that's quick yes sir range
of income during that time take-home pay
is about 140 to 150 thousand cool and
what do you guys do for a living I do
technical work for energy management
company mm-hm
and I'm a registered nurse very good
very cool well you guys are killing
congratulations thank you so what kind
of debt was the one oh not this was baby
step six this was our house hey I'm
looking at weird people's right your
house is paid for I love it well
congratulations you guys that's awesome
so what's this house worth probably 200
225 awesomeness when did you get it paid
off man ah so you've had a chance to
walk through the backyard and know it's
yours yeah indeed very cool feels cooler
I'm telling ya probably need that in
Fort Worth in the summer Oh
so tell me the story what happened 13
months ago it went a little bit earlier
than that in 2008-2009 I was introduced
to your program through a co-worker and
I got the book brought it home and we
kind of you know read a little bit I
think we missed the whole gazelle
intense portion we must have skipped
that chapter or something as we paid off
a few things and then she wanted to go
back to nursing school and we cashflow
dead and then as soon as she got out
mm-hmm it was game on we both looked at
each other and you know we don't want to
look up after a year so of uh you know
her income and go where'd it go there
you go what let's just throw it all at
the house so that's real hard you know
it's like her first paycheck at the
house second paycheck at the house so
she hasn't had to have any fun with her
income whatsoever but you know here we
are over done now you're fun though
sitting there with a paid-for house yeah
this is amazing
very very cool so what is your
recommendation to someone that's
listening and they're down to only
$100,000 out on their house
and what what's the secret that you use
to pay off this debt and I mean
obviously her nursing income coming in
throwing it all at the house yes that
was a big part of the secret big part of
the formula but is there something else
you all noticed in this journey that
that changed about you that you
recommend to others I think for me it's
you know putting the big thermometer up
on the fridge and just seeing it every
day you go get a glass of milk there it
is you know lying through it every month
getting the kids involved they're
checking things off there they're there
watching us go through this whole
process so just being intentional
knowing how much we make and where it's
going it was major the budget mmm your
every dollar really helped oh good it
took a couple of months for us to kind
of get it ironed out but once we got it
going and streamlined it it rarely
changed but we would know every month we
bring in this much and then we had this
extra income and boom it go right to the
house some months we would pay 4,000 off
some months it was 9,000 off Wow
so it just we pick up any shift we could
and we just kept going and going and
going I mean we I miss these kids I
worked a lot of nights and I missed some
baseball games and some recitals but and
you never will again
yeah now you don't have you know
anything you wanna do now your job me
was perfect too because we know every
dollar came out mm-hm
that's when we pretty much started this
whole bang oh yeah and now with your
smart vest here it's like now we're
ready for that so you're appreciated
we're trying to take care of you I'll
just tell you that how very cool so the
young men your your young men with you
ages and names this is a Josh he's 17
and Sean he's 14 awesome very cool he's
about to graduate high school here next
year and he's already signed up for the
Air Force oh well thank you for your
service in advanced college
check there you go I like it yeah thank
you Air Force for that sir very nice
great job and well congratulations you
guys I'm very proud I'm gonna give you a
signed copy of Chris Hogan's book to go
with your smart Wester appointment
retire retire inspired and number one
bestseller because that's I'll help you
continue to build wealth now and live
and give like no one else and that puts
you in a position to do that
how old are you two
44 and your and your house is paid for
you you really have you really grasped
how weird that is I mean this is the
stepping stone right here where I'm
grasping it because it wasn't until I
come onto this show that it's kind of
hitting me now yeah I mean I was like
nobody does this yeah but everybody else
is broke know if you drive down your
street and look at the houses they're
you know none of them it's just you I
mean I've got very unusual if it's more
than you very well done you I'm very
proud of you thank you very very neat
all right Dan and Mary Josh and Shawn
Fort Worth Texas 109,000 their houses
paid out baby their weird
they did it in 13 months making 140
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one that's how it's
done I love it very very very well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 in the common